basically uh i've been
uh on the alpha side for
so long like before i discovered your
uh your channel so i've been spinning
plays and
things like that so yeah i got a
question is is that um so i've been
spinning plates so
uh occasionally i i got some some of the
plates just just like hey uh should you
tell me oh my periods late so that kind
of like freaked me out so
uh well are you using birth control
yes i do use the you know
condom things so
uh yeah some of them not really uh long
story short because uh i pretty know who
they are so
uh
sorry you know where they are in their
cycle is that what you're saying
yes oh you think you're one of those
guys that know where they are in their
cycle huh
yeah so why is she calling you up saying
i think i'm late
yeah so
yeah my question is like if if
they really are pregnant
and for me i don't really want any kids
so what should i do how old are you i'm
and you definitely don't want to have
any kids
definitely not at this point
like ever
okay not at this point but yes you might
be open to it later right
how many girls are you seeing
uh
three
four
and you're attacking all of them
yes okay
and you're not using birth control with
all of them um
[Music]
it's been spinning plates so
two of them are not really using uh
you're gonna run into a problem like
this at some point my man
you know how things work right like i
don't need to explain the birds and the
bees to you
yeah yeah you know how things work right
yeah so
it's called birth control because you
want to control the birth
so your best option is going to be
condoms
a bad backup plan is being a really good
polar router
okay
and your best bet is
some some form of reliable birth control
and if you're
exclusive with these plates like they're
only seeing you
iud
okay because birth control pills they
can forget to take
i forgot to take it i missed one i
missed two or three or i didn't bring
them you know with me over the weekend
just get an iud just stick an iud in
there that's it it's not that big of a
deal
very effective
what i'm trying to say is that the
pleasure is not the same if you
understand what i say it's it's the same
with an iud
there's no difference you don't notice
it
you don't feel anything that's out of
the way
i used i gotta
look it up yeah i think you should look
it up and until you get that sorted out
definitely start using condoms
and if she's pregnant hey
not my problem it's your problem you're
gonna have to you can't have to sort
that one out yourself what do you want
me to do
i don't have a time machine you know
what i'm saying like if i had a time
machine i'd be a very rich man because
then i'd say yo eric hop in my time
machine i'll send you back 30 days let's
fix this one
all right good point
right so going forward
solve that problem yourself and as far
as you know what you're gonna do and and
okay well there's another good point
here too morning after pill plan b
you know what that is
yeah i would use a few times so um yeah
they like uh trying to say well it's not
gonna be uh good for my future
uh birth and this and that because they
they don't really know well well the
plan b shouldn't shouldn't be used as
birth control a plan b should be used as
a plan b if a condom breaks like that's
what it's there for
um it's not particularly good for
anybody's you know for her body
uh so it definitely should not be used
as a as a method of birth control it is
a plan b that's it so use condoms have a
plan b or an iud
i mean
dude what did i say about will smith
complicate life justify why
yeah here i am talking to another man
that complicated his life and now he's
trying to justify why well i've got
these plates and i think i'm you know
i'm okay and now what do i do it's like
well you're gonna have to figure that
out man you're gonna have to figure that
out
you want to talk about some options
offline
the link pinned in the top comment has
my consult line there's some stuff that
i'll talk about offline off the air but
i'm not going to talk about it on the
air you know you're going to have to pay
for that time okay right and by the way
i'm uh like uh other than uh jason woman
but i'm really a big fan of your channel
like um you're giving me the reputation
excellence so
well it's not only clearly clearly i
haven't made the point of using proper
birth control did you read my book
uh not yet uh there's a section in the
book about birth control you know
covered in a couple different places so
you should probably read my book
right i read uh rollo's book uh that's
one chapter i'm talking about
yeah he's got his iron rules right one
of them is uh be in control of the birth
yeah
i absolutely co-signed that
yeah and yet you didn't do that
yeah complicate life justify why
yeah and and that's so
yeah i'm gonna look it up iud
and yeah i'm a big fan of your channel
and uh
jensen netherlands so
okay but a man that chases excellence
doesn't make mistakes like this
because mistakes like this get in the
way of chasing excellence and you're in
full control
of that excellence that you're trying to
chase right i mean
why would you just
spread it all over you know like yeah
we're here to spread our seed
but if you really don't want to have
kids right now and you want to chase
excellence then
then you should make that choice to not
make that mistake
understood wrap that rascal
do you understand what i'm saying here
like i mean
like you know what happens if you knock
up all three or four of these chicks
yeah this is going to be a mess uh right
now just in my early 30 um i'm making
six figures incomes i'm planning to uh
double my income
every year
so i'm on check on that how old are
these women that you're dating
they're like 28
25 uh they're just graduating from
how old how's the one that's mr period
the the one is 28. of course it's just
any face
she wants to have babies
yeah so let me guess let me guess oh you
can go inside me eric i won't get
pregnant right now
something like that
um
well actually it's me is that that like
she's the one always said hey you use
the production so i i'm the one that
like yeah we will need i'm good at the
game
the pulling game are you sure that you
don't want to have kids because you're
certainly acting like you want to have
them
not at this point no but you're acting
like you want to have them
uh
you see what i'm saying right like
you're saying that you don't want to
have kids but you're acting like you
want to have kids
you know how things work right like you
know how plumbing works like i don't i
don't explain that so you're acting like
you want to have kids right so a man
that's chasing excellence like an
unplugged alpha would not make this
mistake
right
i understood that kids is going to be in
the way in my early for for my um oh
dude you have you have no idea what you
know what you're gonna what sort of ways
that you're gonna complicate your life
if you knock up a chick that's just a
plate
that now has your baby that you're now
gonna be on the hook like she's got you
wrapped around her finger now
this finger
i'm i'm very aware of that because my my
dad is a
divorce lawyer then when i was a kid at
that time there was no
like
um my dad would ask me to type those
cases for him so so that so you're right
i am putting it on so i read read them
all i read all kinds of stories so
uh to to me
i heard too many stories
like where do you live you live in
canada in the states where you live
originally i'm from hong kong yeah uh
i've been living in canada for
uh more than 10 years yeah
so it's the same thing yeah and family
not law is not friendly to men here in
situations like this like like you're
going to be on the hook for this big
time i mean
yes my my dad made so much money
uh with those divorce courses and no
miscellaneous cases
so
yeah
it's around the world uh in hong kong in
canada and us
same thing it's good to be a divorce
lawyer well
you're you're still getting distracted
from the real problem here where you've
potentially
drastically changed the course of your
life
yeah
right
right anyway um i got a few other people
waiting to hop on you know the live
stream to ask some questions i try to
keep these to like 10 15 minutes per
person but if you want to talk more
offline the link will be in the top
comment you know you can book me for a
page
coaching session i can give you some
more insight on stuff that i can't talk
about live
oh okay
all right
okay thank you see you but peace
oh man
shivers
muffs in the the chat saying there's no
way he's gonna wrap it after this
i don't understand like you know
you know how it works
like you know how it works why would you
go and expose yourself to that risk
right
you